une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités date site je suis une plante
avec moi pH Quentin et aujourd'hui j'ai
le grand plaisir de recevoir pilou qui
est un chanteur qui est un musicien qui
est un réalisateur d'album qui est un
composteur de musique de film avec qui
j'ai déjà collaboré en fait son studio
enregistré c'était super plaisant et je
rencontrais quelqu'un vraiment fascinant
vraiment intéressant en fait c'est un
des gars les plus
intéressant que j'ai rencontré c'est
quelqu'un avec qui on pourrait parler
des heures que toujours des histoires
que toujours des idées vraiment
fascinantes puis lui en fait il y a
aussi entrepreneur entrepreneur social
en fait nous explique un peu c'est
c'était quoi son cheminement lui a
décidé de quitter Montréal pour se
rétablir en région à Saint-Adrien plus
précisément pas loin de oui agrandi pour
vraiment puissant bu en fait c'est de
créer une communauté de d'artistes de
jeunes entrepreneurs d'ingénieurs de
gens craqué des gens qui veulent
s'investir dans un vivre ensemble
nouveau
dans la région où est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment quelque chose qui se passe
c'est vraiment fascinant en fait je vais
le laisser l'expliquer dans le podcast
mais je pense que ça vous intéresser je
pense à le découvrir une personne
réellement très spéciale et très
intéressante donc ben voilà écoute et au
podcast d'aujourd'hui est présenté par
menscape et aujourd'hui je vous parle du
beauty
pas plus tard qu'hier pour me ramener le
fameux look moustache pour l'été c'est
en fait c'est une tondeuse électrique
pour spécialement faite pour la barre
pour la piloter faciale c'est vraiment
comme tous les produits mascape vraiment
de la bombe en fait j'ai pas besoin de
de vous convaincre de quoi que ce soit
je pense vous le savez déjà et c'est
vraiment pratique on n'a pas besoin de
changer les petits trucs là sur le top
on peut changer la longueur en fait
directement ici sur la tondeuse c'est
waterproof ça va vraiment bien on passe
une fois c'est réglé
on reste pas pris on se fait pas c'est
vraiment super en fait comme tous les
produits moi c'est le c'est le meilleur
le meilleur tondeuse amère le meilleur
Clipper pour la barbe que j'ai utilisé
et avec ça ça vient avec tout un kit
pour l'entretien de votre barbe on a le
shampoing le revitalisant la pommade on
a une petite brosse pour se brosser on a
les ciseaux on a une huile pour la barbe
donc le pied on a même un petit peigne
avec ça vous allez avoir la barbe
parfaite vous allez avoir la barbe
idéale celle dont vous avez toujours
rêvé attendez pas plus pour l'été c'est
important d'avoir une pilosité faciale
parfaite donc ça se passe avec le beauty
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi le film j'ai manqué le début
ça s'appelle
[Rires]
[Musique]
une coupe de semaine puis finalement
j'avais eu un conflit d'horaire
parce que c'est important que je passe
deux jours avec la réalisatrice Ariane
Louis XVI le film ça s'appelle
vampire humaniste chercheuse
on avait eu un genre de préfecture là
fait que fait que ce soit j'ai pris deux
jours composer la musique sur le film
tout ça puis j'aime ce process là parce
qu'il y a après avoir fait deux jours
passent à travers le film avec la Real
là le moteur est repart avec ça il va
replacer la musique il va placer des
trucs et des timings tout ça puis là il
va revenir avec un picture là puis là je
vais déjà avoir plein de matériel pour
m'amuser c'est pour faire le score final
donc avec la Real
finalement
elle est
chaque processus pour les musiques de
films dans le fond c'est différent c'est
chaque film est différent comme ceci
chaque prod d'album est différente
chaque artiste chaque tonne c'est un
process et puis le but c'est de
découvrir le process en en faisant puis
avec Ariane ça fait ça fait quelques
films qu'on fait ensemble j'ai fait deux
courts métrages avec elle puisse son
premier long métrage puis on s'est
vraiment dit-il à dire écoute on arrive
avec on a un assemblage qui est pas loin
du picture là puis
on laisse le moment qu'on le regarde
ensemble c'est fait que on a fait ça sur
deux jours et demi c'est arrivé le
premier soir on a écouté le film puis
moi à la première écoute je m'ouvre tout
le temps un instrument virtuel d'un
piano quelque chose whalever comme ça je
peux au moins si j'ai des idées de
thèmes ou des idées de patente je
m'allume un micro je vais chanter je
vais redonner je vois crier de joie je
vois que puis quand je regarde le fait
que ma première fois
que tu fais pause jus de quoi je fais
même pas pas au salon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la musique référente souvent les
réalisateurs sur la montage ils vont
mettre une musique greffe toute seule
moi je la mets où puis non seulement
quand je peux je demande à une assistant
quelqu'un d'autre de monter la session
je veux même pas la voir je veux savoir
où il y a de la musique
pour tu veux boire dans le logiciel
c'est où que la musique c'est ça je veux
pas voir visuellement c'est qu'ils font
rentrer de la musique parce que je veux
pas que ça m'influence puis des fois il
y a des bouts où comme composteur votre
truc a besoin de musique puis d'autres
fois où il y en a pas besoin puis des
fois la réalisation va avoir mis de la
musique à un endroit où tu fais comme si
j'enlève la musique le jeu des acteurs
est tellement fort la scène est
tellement belle que tu as peut-être
juste besoin d'un centre design ou de
une note mais si tu vas trop appuyer
l'émotion tu parles le truc
de real souvent de décider mais ils font
assez confiance pour dire OK puis lui il
a raison que ça prend pas de musique ou
ça n'en prend là vous n'aurez pas pensé
des fois c'est moi c'est la première
fois que je vois le film fait que c'est
mon premier filing tu sais je vais avoir
lu le scénario avant pour accepter le
projet mais c'est le c'est le premier
gars filing que moi j'ai par rapport au
film puis des fois les réalisateurs puis
les monteurs ben ils sont tellement
attachés à des affaires tellement
attachées au film que pour eux c'est une
évidence que ça prend cela puis moi
j'arrive avec un regard frais puis je
dis ah je sais pas puis là si ils
tiennent vraiment puisqu'ils veulent la
musique bar en bas dans ce boot là puis
une grosse très émotive on va faire ça
parce que il faut aussi faire confiance
à l'instinct du réalisateur qui connaît
son film qui sait ce qu'il veut qui se
passe là
le but je pense de pas avoir des GO
là-dedans juste de dire bah ça c'était
mon premier gode feeling mais peut-être
que c'est pas ça non plus c'est fou
parce que mettons
la trame sonore puis ça va peut-être
être vieux ce que je vais dire mais la
trame sonore d'un film
tu la changes ça change complètement le
film tu sais c'est tellement important
comme comme vecteur d'émotions que que
d'amener ton projet maintenant tu es un
réalisateur mettons on t'a écrit le
scénario aussi te réaliser le film plus
c'est comme ton projet ta vision puis tu
as pas mettons les les aptitudes pour
composer de la musique en plus souvent
c'était scénariste réalisateur t'as pas
mis beaucoup de temps être capable de la
guitare
d'amener ton projet dans comme à
quelqu'un d'autre faire craquer ben là
genre de quoi d'autre aussi important
c'est hors de mes mains
c'est vraiment fou à quel point la
musique type la plupart des gens un film
même moi en fait souvent j'ai que des
films je remarque pas tant la musique
quand je suis dans le film même si je
suis musicien puis que je fais ça des
fois c'est ça le but c'est exactement
mais à quel point met-on c'est comme
subliminal puis ça tape direct dans les
émotions du monde
des vidéos YouTube drôle que tu changes
la musique sur quelque chose puis d'un
coup ça devient genre complètement
l'autre chose là c'est c'est c'est
vraiment puissant le pouvoir de la
musique sans qu'on s'en rende compte
American Psycho avec une tonne pour
faire comme système un film à la
American Pie genre oui c'est juste une
scène comment ça marche bien genre
peut-être l'impression que tu veux
écouter une comédie d'adolescent cave
c'est pour ça que les compositeurs faut
qu'on comprenne c'est notre rôle
là-dedans c'est chic de t'en fais aussi
du fait que mon premier long métrage
très bon là-dedans parce que tu as une
bonne écoute puis je pense que c'est
c'est ça qu'il faut c'est que comme
compositeur de musicalement faut être à
l'écoute du film il faut aussi se mettre
en place du du spectateur tout le temps
le petit sans avoir à le prendre par la
main tu sais les gens sont pas ce sont
pas Nono les spectateurs ils sont
capables aussi de produire leur propre
émotions par rapport aux images qui
voient puis il y a moyen très facilement
avec la musique de faire dérouter une
scène complètement c'est
encore une fois c'est ça si tu appuies
trop quelque chose mettons s'il y a des
c'est déjà triste puis là tu sors les
gros violons puis toi tu as mangé c'est
comme j'ai compris
suggéré une émotion mais pour rendre ça
mais le dramatique ou tirage
exactement à moins que tu fasses une
série de police américaine là ils
veulent que souligne chaque mouvement de
tête chaque mouvement de bras c'est
quasiment comme si le monde a des des
sabres laser d'un bras tout le temps là
il va se passer quoi non on s'en va à la
pause
c'est tellement du divertissement pour
divertissement qui veulent que le monde
puisse mettre leur cerveau à OFF peut
être capable de quand même suivre
l'émotion exactement
puis c'est bas en bas des séries que
j'ai faite ou sur un épisode de 45
minutes il y a 42 minutes et demi de
musique ouais c'est Borama tout le temps
il y a tout le temps un fond tram tout
le temps quelque chose là en fait on dit
on dit américain mais moi ça je suis
comme réabonné au cadre depuis très
récemment là puis
j'écoute le Téléjournal à 6h30 pour 7h
ça tombe sur START à radio qui comme une
émission de d'hôpital un drame d'hôpital
quotidien plus j'écoute ça c'est comme
si je suis le ça commence avec
les autres
quelqu'un qui compose c'est de la
musique je pense à quelqu'un qui
composent parce que c'est
5 jours tout le monde qui travaille sur
des Quotidiennes
demain's top
moi j'admire titre
trouver toutes les thèmes tout ce qui
arrive finalement pratiquement le film
en deux jours et demi moi j'ai eu deux
mois pour faire le film j'ai trouvé ça
recharge trouver sa tête puis je
comprends que c'est une affaire
d'expérience permet
des automatismes puis peut-être aussi
peut-être que j'ai peut-être que j'ai
mis 45 trac j'aurais pu la mettre 12 je
vais arrêter correct aussi peut-être
savoir arrêter mais mais ouais
ça finit à 96
d'être capable de poncer rapidement ça
m'impressionne ouais ben je pense que
c'est un espèce de
trucs que j'ai développé c'est avec les
années quand j'étais jeune je faisais
beaucoup d'impro musical c'est avec des
promo musical avec des soirées de James
au Quai des Brumes à l'Esco les lundi
les mercredis tout de suite on dirait
tout le temps je faisais beaucoup
d'impôts musicales aussi au
Conservatoire avec les collègues
effectivement on a improvisé autant dans
le style baroque que dans le style pop
rock quand jazz fait que quand
j'improvise sur un film quand
j'improvise sur une image ou quand j'ai
besoin d'aller taper dans une émotion
probablement vu que je suis multi
instrumentiste aussi je peux aller vers
toutes sortes de Times toutes sortes des
fêtes toutes sortes de trucs puis les
mélodies pour moi ça vient quand même
assez clairement puis la construction
d'un film puis d'un score aussi c'est à
force de faire depuis 15 ans
j'ai développé des réflexes des recettes
mais qui sont tout le temps renouvelés
c'est avec
non plus les compositeurs qui fait la
même affaire sur chaque film que non
c'est ça exactement chaque film carrière
de 20 ans elle est où avec ça toujours
le même truc ouais ouais non c'est vrai
c'est vrai tu vas lui mettre
les plus grands souvent un film à
l'autre c'est comme une palette
complètement différente des couleurs
puis de procéder des techniques
c'est ça dépend vraiment du je veux non
sortons un petit peu de ça ouais
t'entendre parler parce que je
t'entendais à Tout le monde en parle
parler de ton retour ben ton retour ton
exil de la ville dans le fond
transposer à Saint-Adrien puis c'est
quelque chose que moi je parle quand
même souvent sur le Podcast de comme
l'espèce d'anxiété la ville puis l'envie
de peut-être m'éloigner éventuellement
plus évidemment j'ai quitté une ville
pour une autre j'étais à Québec c'est
déjà moins dense moins pire mais j'ai
quand même encore cet aspect là de
vouloir sortir de la ville
éventuellement c'est quoi qui a été
l'élément déclencheur qui a fait le faut
que je m'en aille mais
c'est drôle parce que tu sais en ce
moment c'est vraiment c'est à la mode
c'est le trend de sortir de la ville
d'aller vers les régions ça fait un ça
fait 12 ans
puis je trouve ça vraiment magnifique
que maintenant justement c'est notre
génération puis même les plus jeunes
fassent et le l'avenir et peut-être pas
à Montréal et peut-être pas Québec puis
peut-être dans nos régions parce que
tout est à bâtir en région
tout est à rebâtir
puis pas qu'il y a rien en région il y a
plein de choses qui sont là il y a plein
acquis qui sont là il y a des choses à
consolider mais c'est ce qu'ils font
là-dedans je trouve c'est que
Geneviève puis moi tu sais on avait 26
ans on était à Montréal elle avait son
atelier son appart moi vraiment studio
mon condo
puis on était les deux ensemble puis on
se disait c'est fou le tir en ce moment
on travaille pour payer des hypothèques
on travaille pour payer des loyers on
travaille comme des fous
pour avoir une qualité de vie qu'on
réussira peut-être jamais à atteindre en
ville parce que c'est tellement cher
puis
aussi tiens on aime le grand air on
sortait tout le temps à la campagne les
week-ends
on se déplaçait puis on se dit on aimait
mieux être sur le bord d'une rivière que
c'est le bord de la 40 maintenant
le déclic c'est vraiment fait là j'ai eu
un espèce d'épiphanie quand j'étais en
Chine en 2010 pour
l'exposition universelle
euh j'ai eu la chance d'aller là-bas
trois semaines avec la délégation
canadienne pour faire des concerts avec
Marie-Jo Thériault puis on avait quatre
concerts en trois semaines fixé on a
fait quatre choses devant des foules de
100000 personnes
en CHINE à Shanghai puis entre les
quatre spectacles bon on est on faisait
partie de la délégation canadienne fait
que on a la des premières de films mon
temps invité à des 5 à 7 à des souper à
des grosses tables d'honneur c'est
magique j'ai vécu genre mon best life à
Shanghai pendant trois semaines on était
dans des dans des penhouse dans les
grands hôtels c'était merci le Cirque du
Soleil et le gouvernement du Canada
d'avoir organisé tout ça pour mes pour
mes pour mes 25 ans
c'est qui qui vient qui vient carrément
d'un trou c'est un endroit où il y a un
immense trou avec
littéralement quand tu regardes la map
du Québec au milieu c'est à ce bestos
fait que c'était spécial puis en même
temps là-bas j'étais dans mon hôtel
comme au 36e étage j'ai plus là je
regardais autour je me disais my god il
y a du monde sa planète il y a tellement
de Mondeville puis j'avais eu le même
genre de révélation quand j'avais 7 ans
puis j'étais venu à Montréal pour la
première fois que je m'en rendais compte
on n'était pas assez de
Outremont à Notre-Dame de Grâce par le
mont Royal de nuit tiens Noël là je
voyais toutes les lumières de la ville
puis je disais à mes parents ça c'est
c'est quoi toute cette étendue de
lumière là qu'on voit puis il me disait
mais ça c'est les gens c'est la ville
c'est la Ville de Montréal puis là c'est
tellement grand pour moi que je m'étais
mis à pleurer ça m'avait comme
bouleversé qui aille autant de monde
dans un endroit j'étais genre oh shit
puis là j'ai eu la même chose à 25 ans
en Chine j'ai fait ok le c'est sérieux
le tigre
est dégueulasse on voit pas on voit pas
10 pieds devant nous à cause de à cause
du smog à cause de la pollution
ça pue partout j'étais comme ok ça se
peut pas quand je suis revenu à Montréal
c'est là que j'ai décidé j'ai dit ok je
peux aller n'importe où dans le monde
faire de la tournée comme ça travailler
faire mon métier mais quand je reviens
chez nous ça peut pas être ça chez nous
ça peut pas être mon condo dans shlag
puis mon studio puis là de toute façon
le studio vous savez comment c'est tu
construis des studios un bail commercial
ton bail fini tu te fais mettre à porte
tu sais les rénovictions
très bien moi j'ai construit trois
studios à Montréal comme un
clowns
dehors puis là la troisième fois j'avais
mon studio avec Ben Charest au coin
Saint-Urbain Mont-Royal puis on a fait
créé mon construis-tu un xiam studio à
Montréal est-ce que la Ville de Montréal
a vraiment besoin d'un autre studio je
pense pas fait que c'est à partir de là
que j'ai décidé parce que aussi je
faisais beaucoup de musique de films
puis de trucs pour l'Europe les
États-Unis via Skype avec des fois je
rencontrais même pas les real je
recevais les trucs je faisais la musique
je l'ai envoyé toute par Internet
il y a 12-13 ans faites-le j'ai fait je
peux faire mon métier de n'importe où
dans le monde puis le trip au début
c'était de dire je vais acheter un
terrain au bord de la mer au Mexique
puis je vais faire mon studio là je
travaille de là puis là il est arrivé le
village où on voulait s'installer il y a
eu genre des fusillades cette semaine là
et le dos de avec qui on peut se poser
pour le terrain il est disparu
avec 150000 pièces de stocks
ouais c'est ça j'arrive avec toute mon
studio parfait la vanne c'est donc le
projet Mexique
et est mort dans l'oeuf peut-être avec
le dos qui devait nous voir mais bref
c'était c'était un peu sketch fait que
là on sait je me suis dit ah bah tiens
ok le Mexique non mais la campagne au
Québec peut-être là on s'est mis à
regarder à 1h de Montréal à 1h30 de
Montréal puis là c'était soit pas
achetable ou c'était dans le milieu d'un
champ avec plein de plein de de maïs
génétiquement modifié tout le tour puis
on se disait on va tu vraiment habiter à
maryville au milieu d'un champ au roi
rouge mon milieu d'un champ
fait que au bout de nos recherches à
Manille j'ai fait ben si on va deux
heures de Montréal moi je viens d'un
coin qui est la MRC des Sources
qui est méconnu qui est en pleine
revitalisation à cause de la fermeture
des mines d'amiante fait qu'il y avait
des incitatifs pour les jeunes familles
à venir s'installer puis on est
carrément tombé sur le jackpot dans le
fond le
venait visiter des maisons puis
finalement c'est le buste d'avoir une
maison avec une grande pour transformer
la grange en studio puis en atelier pour
ma blonde
puis finalement j'ai croisé un de mes
jambes d'enfance Étienne Pellerin pour
ne pas le nommer un feu de camp le
vendredi soir byrunder ça c'est un autre
demi-chium comme eux ils font un feu on
y va je vois toutes mes jambes
secondaires tout ça piétienne
où on allait se promener quand on était
jeune à quatre roues puis tout ça ils
disent mon père a découvert que ces
zones et blanc fait qu'on puisse
construire il peut nous vendre des
terrains puis vœux nous vendre des
terrains à moi pumacher
notre quartier drive fait que ça ça
s'appelle espace nature petit âme
pi on est allé le lendemain on a cassé
les toutes nos visites de maison on est
à la Saint-Adrien qui est une banlieue
dans ce Besta
puis là c'est comme La petite séduction
là c'était le festival du bûcheron
d'antan sur le terrain de balle il y
avait un spectacle de Madame Moustache
il y avait il y avait des kids qui
couraient partout tout le monde est faim
il y avait pas toujours un marché
naturel organique à tous les dimanches
c'est un gros samedi le steak comme il y
avait du monde
ok c'est fou c'est plus le père à mon
ami nous a pris en calèche avec les
chevaux il nous a amené visiter terrain
l'enté genre mais ok mais parfait si
sauf que là le truc ce qui avait pas de
maison on a acheté une forêt puis là mon
ami Étienne encore une fois qui m'a
convaincu il dit moi j'ai construit ma
maison si j'étais capable tout est
capable fait que ah ouais
c'est comme ça que ça a commencé cette
affaire là on voulait sortir de la ville
puis à force de pas trouver ce qu'on
voulait puis qui est rien vraiment qui
nous parle ben on achète une forêt puis
on a décidé de construire notre maison
tu sais mais on savait pas dans quoi on
s'embarquer c'est 26 ans
construit ma maison jamais fait ça en
plus on a fait trois maisons le même été
est-ce que c'était juste toutes tes amis
dans le fond vous construisiez les
maisons c'était juste truffe à blonde
c'était moi ma blonde avec mon père qui
est pas un gars de la construction qui
est un travailleur social et musicien
retraités
avec avec mon avec mon voisin qui lui
avait construit sa maison l'année
d'avant que ça je vais vous donner une
coupe de trucs je vais vous donner un
coup de main puis un autre de nos amis
qui est qui est ingénieur mais surtout
très ingénieux puis de bons conseils qui
nous a conseillés tout ça puis on a fait
vraiment une auto-construction peut
réduire ouais fait que on a toute
contracté on a tout fait nos autres même
on a coupé le bois on a sorti le bois
avec des champs avec des chevaux on a
amené ça au moulin assis on a fait tir
le bois on obtient de A à Z c'est débile
ça a pris quand un été juste un été 8
mois
8 mois elle est trop basse
avec Ariane
on est venu enregistrer chez vous puis
je sais pas qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
ce coin-là tu fais partie de cet
écosystème-là qui fait que c'est un coin
qu'on dirait qui est en pleine genre
plein de beaux me culturels mais il y a
vraiment une vague dans ce village-là
l'Église qui est convertie maintenant
que que des bureaux mettez dans un
endroit de cinéma et puis de toutes
sortes d'affaires justement les épicerie
bio 24 heures
on dirait que c'est justement c'est
comme le André c'est en fait la le
village du futur un peu l'espèce de
retour mais où est-ce que tout est
traditionnel mais en même temps tout est
super moderne puis tout est comme
optimisé pour une genre de vie je
demande collective et genre de
collective mais de 2023 ouais mais c'est
ça pitié aussi très basé sur des valeurs
d'antan tu mettons la confiance
c'est ouvert 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 employé pour les membres il y a
pas d'employés
si on essaye qu'il y a des gens s'il y a
des membres qui viennent passer des
journées des fois tu es tout un
quelqu'un qui fait l'inventaire qui
arrange des trucs de 9 à 5 il y a
souvent quelqu'un pour aider les clients
c'est ouvert au public mais entre les
heures d'ouverture comme membre tu peux
y aller tu as une petite puce
électronique tu ouvres la porte tu
rentres tu fais tes achats c'est
libre-service avec le iPad puis un
square l'inventaire est toute
automatisée tout ça fait que c'est quand
même quasiment manqué de trucs il y a
une commande automatique qui part pour
pour dire une alerte on commence à
manquer des rives faudrait checker ça
fait que puis aussi tu sais c'est
beaucoup de la création de liens ce truc
là le saint vrac maintenant opinion sur
rue au coin de la rue tu sais mais si on
avait démarré ça dans l'Église c'est la
dans la foulée de l'achat de l'église
puis de l'ouverture des portes de
l'église à des projets communautaires
justement culturel qu'on a dit ben
utilisons cet espace là pour démarrer
des trucs puis une fois qu'ils vivent de
même mais ils pourront
occuper le territoire ailleurs mais tout
en gardant un lien
ensemble
[Musique]
on dirait que chacun de tes projets
parce que tu mettes plus on parle
longtemps plus
plus il y a des projets qui sortent que
ça j'avais jamais entendu parler de ça
mais happy
en fait justement cette semaine là
c'était comme c'était la semaine qu'on
est enregistrer chez vous c'était comme
un peu
là aujourd'hui j'ai vernissage à tel
place pour les offres ma blonde puis
telent comme on dirait que chaque
journée était avec comme 12 projets
montrer que chacun de ces projets là
commence à par
comme ton histoire tantôt j'ai croisé un
quelqu'un par hasard un chum on se met à
jaser c'est devenu un projet tu sais
puis
je trouve ça incroyable en fait comment
j'ai l'impression qu'il était comme
quelqu'un qui qui attire ce genre
d'affaires-là de qui je parle avec ça ça
donne une idée on va faire ça puis là
d'un coup il y a des affaires qui se
passe ben oui c'est ça puis tu sais
aussi il y a il y a le truc c'est de moi
je parle des choses c'est il y a des
gens ils vont attendre que ça soit fait
de A à Z avant de lancer quelque chose
puis l'autre doser puis la nanana moi
j'en parle pour qu'il y ait des gens qui
se mettent à gravité autour du projet
que ça a un effet d'entraînement puis
qu'on puisse le réaliser ensemble parce
que je sais que tout seul je peux pas
réaliser tous ces projets là par contre
si j'ai l'idée la vision puis que je
scène la graine dans dans la tête de
d'autres personnes ben ces gens-là vont
finir par se sentir concerné par se
mobiliser puis par dire Akrim ça tiens
on devrait le faire plus et rappelle
sont comme happy looter ton idée l'autre
jour de faire ça on pense ça serait une
bonne idée plus comme ok ben trouvons le
meilleur véhicule pour faire arriver ce
projet-là puis essayons de le structurer
de manière à ce que ça ça devienne
possible puis peut-être que le projet va
changer en cours de route qui va avoir
des nouvelles personnes qui vont se
rattacher qui va vous mais au final le
but c'est que ça se passe
le statu quotidien quand on se dit ah
c'est le même parce que c'est le même on
a toujours fait ça de même plus que ça
va continuer Notre-Dame
je voudrais faire ça mais que aucune
action est prise pour faire ça fait que
finalement c'est ça des fois si
20% de ce que dans ma tête ce
matérielise puisse réalise ben ça sera
déjà ça mais moi j'aime ça parler du
100% parce que il y a un 80% là-dedans
que je trouve qui est important c'est
puis je me rends compte c'est avec le
temps puis avec les actions concrètes
qu'on finit par y arriver
mais ça c'est pas fait du jour au
lendemain tu sais que la pi c'est
quelque chose que ça m'a appris d'avoir
construit ma maison en 2012 c'est que
tout est possible parce que quand j'ai
annoncé à toutes les chaumes à Montréal
en 2011 et je me suis acheté une paire
de 16 heures qu'avec Geneviève on
construit notre maison l'été prochain
nous-mêmes on déménage là puis on
construit un studio un atelier puis une
maison puis on rénove la vieille grange
puis c'est ça le plan on s'en va vivre
dans le fin fond des bois puis dates
personnes vont venir là-bas comment tu
vas faire tes gays comment tu vas faire
pour le studio comment ça va faire puis
la morale de l'histoire c'est que la
première année d'ouverture du studio
ben les chiffres parlent ça on a
quintuple chiffre d'affaires de la
compagnie c'est en déménageant campagne
tout le monde pensait qu'on allait
perdre aux changes puis finalement non
on a 15 plus de chiffre d'affaires puis
les artistes aiment ça venir aussi mais
c'est ça parce que c'est une expérience
parce que tu il y a pas de réseau
cellulaire parce que il y a le saint
vrac il y a de la bouffe locale puis des
bombes des bonnes petites bouteilles de
cidre local poétiqueté c'est bon
de plus de demandes plus d'artistes plus
de réalisations d'album ou plus de films
scoring plus de les deux en fait c'est
cette année-là
bon c'est sûr que c'est ça a aidé ça a
été l'année où j'ai fait le film de
Denis que ça a été mon premier gros
score en fait la première année et demi
qu'on était au studio c'est un des
premiers films que j'ai faite là-dedans
le règne de la beauté
j'ai fait la foire et l'ordre de
Philippe braque qu'on ne coproduit
ensemble c'est sur mon modèle de
co-production que je fais depuis 15 ans
peut-être avec les artistes
effectivement on a coproduit la foire et
là il y a eu plusieurs albums dans ces
années là depuis plusieurs artistes qui
sont venus plusieurs musiques de films
aussi fait que ça contribué mais il y a
aussi le fait que
je payais plus un méga gros loyer ceint
Mont-Royal
le condo le studio l'appart l'atelier du
combine ça puis là c'est tout dans le
même panier sur un terrain sur une terre
agriculture agricole maison des blanches
à Saint-Adrien fait que c'est sûr que ça
rationalisait nos dépenses toutes les
affaires puis aussi Geneviève ces
années-là a tourné dans haut à TVA
factice des gros mois de tournages des
des grosses années le pour elle de
tournage en ville mais en même temps ça
tourne pendant deux mois puis après à le
10 mois dans l'année pour être à la
maison en campagne seul c'est fun sa
peinture puis développer toutes ces
autres affaires tu parles de ton modèle
de coproduction ouais c'est quoi tu
l'expliquer bah en fait avec les
artistes que je produis que je coproduit
tu sais il y a toujours des droits
inhérents aux bancs de maîtresse puis
aux éditions puis moi depuis 15 ans j'ai
ma maison d'édition
souvent des artistes qui par exemple
sont émergents peuvent pas payer du
temps studio peuvent pas payer pour la
réalisation pour tout ça il arrive avec
une tonne ou des bouts de tunes qui
veulent faire réaliser produire moi j'ai
les studios puis la réalisation puis
tout ça fait ce qu'on fait mais c'est
que au lieu que moi je devienne le
producteur puis que je les paye pour
qu'il joue sur les bancs de maîtresses
puis que j'aille 100% des bancs de
maîtresses mais je dis on le fait
ensemble conjointement on sépare les
bancs de maîtresse 55 ans moi je fournis
les studios la Real toi tu fourni les
tonnes puis ton talent puis après le
studio fourni tout ce qui est
équipement mixage mastering nana tout ça
Peter
puis la création des oeuvres aussi
conjointement se fait souvent en studio
parce que tu les artistes arrivent il y
a une bonne idée de tonne guide voix
mais des fois on va rajouter un bridge
après la gestion des droits se fait par
burnhouse pabloching fait ce qui fait
que toutes les musiques de films que
j'ai faites à 95%, je pense puis les
albums aussi que j'ai réalisé
studio le nid qui m'accompagne a une
part d'édition puis une part de bandes
maîtresse donc je fais pas d'argent
maintenant mais sur le long terme dans
50 ans mais ayants droits vont encore
récolter les fruits de ce qu'on a fait
Lotter je trouve que ce qui est le fun
pour un artiste c'est que comme
producteur comme réalisateur j'ai
intérêt à ce que ça soit le meilleur
album possible les meilleurs tonnes
possible parce que je suis coin
investisseur exact puis là il y a
d'autres modèles qui vont découler de ça
maintenant c'est le écouli crowdfunding
qui est basé justement sur la revente de
d'un catalogue d'édition par exemple un
dans le même genre de modèle un artiste
pourrait dire moi je veux faire mon
prochain album j'ai pas un rond pour le
faire vous êtes mes fans vous êtes 100
000 donnez-moi chacun une pièce je vais
avoir 100000 pièces pour faire mon album
puis pour ça les cent mille personnes
qui vont donner une pièce je vais vous
donner 10% de mes real tease pour
toujours
faites-le les 100.000 femmes viennent de
s'engager dans la carrière de l'artiste
l'artiste lui va créer son album puis
après il vient d'avoir une presse puis
un fanb base qui va avoir intégrer à ce
que le reste de la planète écoute cet
album là parce que chaque fois que ça
tourne sur Spotify chaque fois que ça
joue à Radio il faut 10 % de ça
c'est des c'est des trucs un collègue
Guillaume desiels chez allocentrique
développe que l'ancien gérant des
valeurs puis tout ça
qu'une maison d'édition aussi puis on
collabore sur des projets puis je trouve
ça vraiment intéressant puis même un
moyen c'est encore plus poussé de faire
une gestion de ces droits-là qui serait
de d'adosser c'est par là éditorial sur
un contrat un smart contracte sur la
blockchain
fait qu'à ce moment-là toutes les gens
qui ont des adresses blockchain qui ont
des adresses numériques quand il y a une
pièce qui rentre sur ce projet là mais
le 17 qui doit être redistribué va être
redistribué directement sur les adresses
tout de suite enfin que tu peux avoir
100000 adresses pour une scène puis ça
se calcule toutes ces fractions-là ça se
ça se dépose automatiquement ouais c'est
fou c'est fou puis là tu parles de
plus tantôt toutes les projets toutes
les idées qui deviennent tout à faire là
mais en même temps derrière tout cette
cette espèce d'aspect
imaginatif et créatif il y a un petit
casse-tête
logistique logistique fiscale et
entreprenariale
aussi en toi où il y a du monde autour
de toi qui sont qui ont tout au dessus
les idées puis après si tu délègues un
peu ou c'est toi qui qui gère tout seul
c'est un parce que plus il y a le projet
ça devient débile mental c'est clair
mais tu es dans dans la plupart des
projets il y a des associés qui sont
dans le projet qui sont complémentaires
avec moi menton ça prend oui quelqu'un
qui tient les cordons de la bourse
quelqu'un qui qui fait du développement
stratégique qui fait t-il il y a des
gens qui sont un peu dans dans chacune
des entreprises dans chacune des
verticales il y a des gens qui sont là
qui sont responsables c'est des
directeurs générales ou des chargés de
projet
non parce que sinon ça se pourrait juste
pas ça fait peut-être 8 ans que
quelqu'un qui s'occupe de mon
administration dans les différents
projets il y a différentes films
comptables qui s'occupent que ces
projets-là fonctionnent fait que dans
ces sociétés
différents avec des associés ou pas ou
avec des chargées de projet mais c'est
certain que c'est pas moins qui fait
arriver toutes ces choses là moi j'étais
à la base à l'idéation puisque je veux
c'est créer de la valeur puis créer de
la valeur pour ma communauté pour les
gens avec qui je travaille et par le
biais développer des nouveaux modèles
qui vont servir à toute la société
éventuellement c'est concrètement c'est
quoi en fait les différents mettons
qu'on sépare ton cerveau entre les
différents projets qu'on fait la
l'éventail c'est quoi les principaux
mais ton truc qui devrait pas le libérer
finalement dans lesquels s'investis sur
le nid c'est la même parce que ces
studios Lenny qui a permis de développer
pas mal tout le reste puis ce qui est
intéressant là-dedans c'est que on a
développé un modèle de développement
territorial à Saint-Adrien accès
beaucoup sur la culture
factice
culture l'élément c'est productions
visuelle
puis maison d'édition puis studio
d'enregistrement ça ça a créé de
l'activité économique dans la MRC ça a
créé un espèce de de Outlook puis pas
mal tout découlé de ça parce que si on
regarde le BIM le bureau Astrid
l'audiovisuel et du multimédia mais
l'Église que tu as acheté qui est dans
l'église exactement mais le BIM est
arrivé beaucoup à cause d'un constat que
j'avais qui était que comme compositeur
de musique à l'image j'étais en contact
avec des producteurs en industrie des
producteurs à Montréal un peu partout
dans le monde qui me contactait moi pour
que je le retrouve des lieux de tournage
en région je me suis penché ce club j'ai
dit
il y a personne qui fait ça trouver des
lieux de tournage en esprit c'est dans
la région pourquoi est-ce qu'il se
tourne vers le compositeur du film pour
les aider
si on pose cette question là à moi qui a
aucune expertise donc ça ça veut dire
que personne avec une expertise qui peut
le faire exactement
une grande rouge avec possiblement deux
ski-doubs des années 70 ça a été la
femme c'était quand même voilà la grange
à Picardie parce que en fait quand même
réponse exactement
que j'ai produit mon premier vidéo clip
pour Kygo c'est quand même un artiste de
Singapour
j'ai produit un clip pour Kygo parce
qu'au début j'étais fixé pour la pour la
gigue pour un producteur de Montréal
puis j'avais tout trouvé c'est un besoin
genre de 60 figures à 20 véhicules des
quatre roues des chants des toutes là on
a été trouvé puis moi j'avais déjà
engagé du monde si j'avais déjà donné
puis là deux jours avant le producteur
de Montréal m'appelle puis il fait comme
je tire la plug il dit c'est trop
ambitieux comme projet ça se peut pas on
peut pas faire sans régions c'est trop
compliqué
plus moi j'ai me clasher 3 semaines de
travail pour trouver ce monde-là booker
il est là toute bouquet à faire puis là
tu m'enlèves ça puis en plus là ça
faisait une coupe de fois que je faisais
le futur pour des prods je suis allé
voir les gens de la MRC de ma région que
j'avais dit Hey Amani on fait venir elle
est ici Hollywood va venir ici voir des
Américains ici ils vont venir tourner
puis là on va revirer ça le titre on
utilise la main d'oeuvre spécialisée sur
notre territoire pour capturer la
ressource qui nous paysages puis nos
talents pour des intérêts étrangers fait
que c'est comme c'est comme si c'était
une compagnie minière même capté la
ressource
bref le 2 jours avant le tournage le
producteur de Montréal il dit non ça se
passera pas mais là j'ai dit ben moi je
vais le faire arriver donne moi le
contacter
ça a marché
bref deux jours plus tard il y avait une
équipe de 8 américains un directeur
photo et mérite un grand réalisateur
toute une belle gagne pour les produire
le clip de Kygo puis c'est studio Lenny
qui est qui a été pro d'exécuté puis une
coupe de semaine avant on avait fait un
clip pour Dany Placard avec un jeune
producteur que j'ai vraiment aimé qui
s'appelle Sam Caron qui était l'escope
film maintenant puis Sam il me disait
moi le 2-3 ans je veux faire des grosses
prodes américaines là je l'ai appelé
deux semaines après
qu'est-ce que tu fais la semaine
prochaine tu t'en viens avec moi on
produit un clip pour Kygo en face
ensemble ça va être capoté puis on le
fait bon c'est on n'a pas dormi pendant
huit jours j'ai pleuré je sais plus
combien de centaines de fois pendant
toute le temps là de joie de tristesse
de colère de de genre qu'est-ce qu'on
fait
vous allez voir le clip c'est stargazing
de Kygo puis tu sais on a construit un
vaisseau spatial il y a un autre homme
qui a construit une navette spatiale de
30 pieds de long on a fait de la
pyrotechnie on a on a pris beaucoup de
choses pendant ce temps là c'est fou
c'est comme construire une maison à 8
mois exactement
mais je pense c'est ça le fun c'est de
faire des nouvelles affaires mais là ça
m'a vraiment fait comprendre puis ça m'a
fait réaliser que on avait besoin de
réactiver le bureau du cinéma et de la
télévision de l'esprit c'est il y avait
jadis un bureau de cinéma en Estrie
qui était inactif depuis peut-être 15
ans fait que là ça fait 20 ans tu sais
il y a un bureau de cinéma de la
télévision du Québec à Montréal
c'est qui est financé puis que ça ça va
bien il y a tirer des tournages à
Montréal on n'a pas de problème à
remplir les studios même que faudrait
construire beaucoup plus de studios si
on l'a vu dans 10 dernières années
Toronto Vancouver son passé de 5 à 22
studios le titre c'est des ça pas
partout à Montréal faut qu'on fasse ça
aussi mais à l'extérieur de Montréal
c'est le fun aussi c'est faire des prods
fait que c'est ça qu'on a voulu mettre
de l'avant en fondant le BIM on s'est
dit ça va nous prendre des bureaux ça va
nous prendre place pour faire des
studios notre spécialité c'est quoi nos
autres ben c'est le son c'est le son
puis l'image on a du monde en Estrie qui
développe plein de trucs on a des
directeurs photos puis
on s'est rendu compte aussi c'est à
travers le shoot avec avec la gang de
Kygo une journée notre première
assistant caméra pouvait pas être là
genre jour 3 puis là on rechait vraiment
trouver quelqu'un pour tirer le point ça
tirer le point c'est faire le focus des
lentilles
job hyper pointu puis complexe puis
genre le baptême là on l'a fait le tour
personne pouvait puis il y a quelqu'un
qui dit avez-vous pensé à
Jocelyn Smart plante est comme à
Jocelyne
Jocelyn le cheval blanc
qui on savait ce monsieur là il était
caméraman à Radio-Canada puis qui était
c'est un bon caméraman mais Caroline
c'est un assistant calme un premier
assistant qui a fait genre 7 ans au
Tibet avec Brad Pitt qui a fait plein de
gros films américains c'est genre le top
notch que les Américains veulent
travailler avec lui quand ils merci puis
habite dans notre village plan l'a
appelé qui était libre le lendemain
matin puis on a même pas besoin de le
faire venir de Montréal il était déjà là
si lui est là tu imagines tu le nombre
de talents qui a autour de Saint-Adrien
puis en esterie puis des bois frappent
autour qui ont des chalets là ou qui ont
des maisons là mais qui reviennent à
Montréal travailler j'ai dit pourquoi
est-ce que leur job peut pas exister
dans leur région
on a fondé le BIM en se disant on va
rassembler ces talents là on va se
donner des lieux on va se donner des
équipements de pointe on va se donner un
hub créatif pour co-créer ensemble ce
monde-là ou nos jobs existent en région
c'est vraiment je trouve ça tellement on
disait je t'entends parler puis je
trouve c'est un genre de
un genre de de
capitalisme qui est
qui redonne on dirait je sais pas
comment bien le définir là parce qu'on
dirait que c'est il y a de la prophète
profitabilité dans ton truc
il débarque là
c'est 100000 US de retomber dans un
village de 500 habitants on dirait on
dirait que ça m'apparaît comme quand je
me positionne sur genre l'avenir puis le
futur on dirait que
parce que je veux reculer d'un pas
parler de décroissance je suis pas sûr
que ça me ça me parle parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme impossible
par la nature de l'homme c'est l'homme
veut tout le temps l'homme
meilleur puisse améliorer puis je pense
c'est une des choses qui fait qu'on est
qui on est qu'on est qu'on est capable
de se dépasser puis de repousser nos
limites parce que c'est intéressant ça
fait quand tu rentres le facteur
monétaire dans ce tour là ça reste un
enjeu fait je pense pas que la
décroissance est la suite mais on dirait
que ce modèle là m'apparaît tellement
simple et genre collectif puis
intéressant bien qui a un aspect de
profitabilité puis de de création
d'emplois puis de croissance économique
en fait là
en fait c'est
le truc derrière ça c'est que c'est du
slow money
je dois faire un autre parallèle d'un
autre bois qui existe qui est projet
1606 qui est un accélérateur de
transition puis une compagnie
d'investissement immobilier impact donc
cette compagnie là a été créée dans la
foulée de l'achat de l'église mais
maintenant c'est diversifié puis
possèdent d'autres bâtiments immobiliers
dans le village de Saint-Adrien et à
l'extérieur puis l'idée de l'industrie
principalement puis éventuellement
peut-être ailleurs au Québec
l'idée derrière l'investissement
immobilier impact c'est dire il y a des
bâtiments en ce moment qui sont
sous-utilisés dans nos régions qui sont
encore 5 sont encore beaux pas sain dans
le sens de sein mais en bon état
et puis que si on les investigait puis
s'il y avait des activités qui se
passaient dedans mais peut-être que on
pourrait attirer des gens à venir monter
des projets là-dedans enfin le but de
l'immobilier impact c'est de maintenir
des bâtiments sur 20 30 40 ans c'est du
long terme c'est dire on va développer
l'écosystème culturel entrepreneurial
puis sociale puis communautaire autour
de ces bâtiments et dans ses
bâtiments-là en injectant du capital
dans des projets structurants puis des
projets porteurs pour tous pour la
communauté puis le ou t il y a de
l'incompréhension par rapport à ce
modèle là c'est que les gens ils disent
ouais mais c'est une compagnie
d'investissement privée aux autres ils
veulent des rendements ils veulent des
rendements des rendements des rendements
mais les rendements ils vont venir
si ton écosystème se développe puis si
les entreprises autour des bâtiments
puis autour de l'immobilier se
développent puis si le village prend de
la valeur et que la vie de tout le monde
s'améliore puis que l'indice de bonheur
augmente puis que le nombre de légumes
bio qui poussent sur à proximité
augmente puis que le nombre de garderies
augmente puis que le nombre d'élèves à
l'école augmente parce qu'il y a plus de
construction puis que les constructions
sont plus écologiques parce que le
meilleur conscience puis qu'on explique
bien les choses mais là toutes les
systèmes s'élèvent puis là tu vas avoir
un retour sur investissement parce que
le bâtiment tu vas avoir acheté 100 000
en 2010 ben en 2025 mais il va valoir
250 000 mais pas on s'endort qu'on est
loin de acheter un condol le rénover
puis le flipper pour 575000
c'est un long flip puis c'est un flip
qui va avoir de l'impact
pour tout le monde
mais éventuellement c'est ce le but
c'est pas de flipper c'est d'avoir créé
cette valeur là puis une fois que le
bâtiment est clair mais
la valeur qui est là fait qu'après ça
peut devenir ça peut être passé à une
fille d'ici foncière à
usage social après comme propriétaire tu
peux dire ben moi le bâtiment
patrimonial qu'on a acheté il y a 20 ans
maintenant il est clair
on a des loyers qui rentrent parce que
les organismes qui sont à l'intérieur
ils font bien tout ça fait qu'il y a un
10000 par mois qui rentre puis là tu dis
à Desjardins avec votre fille foncière à
usage social racheter le bâtiment au
prix de l'évaluation puis vous allez
avoir un rendement chaque mois ça va ça
va faire des rendements faites-le
Desjardins pas besoin de ripoteki pour
acheter le bâtiment ils peuvent juste
prendre de l'argent d'une fille qui
foncière acheter le bâtiment payer
les loyers à chaque mois à ce moment-là
ça fait des rendements pour les
fiduciaires tout le monde est content
puis moi j'ai mis en place ce modèle là
juste pour que ça se passe puis on le
fait à l'époque il y a 10 ans avec la
menerie qui est une salle communautaire
qui est un organisme qu'on a qu'on a
fondé une dizaine d'années
puis on le fait pour ce bâtiment là au
début mais sans savoir qu'on était en
train de développer un modèle
d'investissement immobilier impact parce
que Fred puis moi les deux
copropriétaires
on a décidé de faire le loyer le moins
cher possible à l'organisme pour pas
mettre de la pression à l'organisme puis
on a mis aussi beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'huile de coude dans
l'organisme pour le développer puis
maintenant c'est un organisme qui a un
employé temps plein qu'un chiffre
d'affaires considérable pour un OBNL
dans un village de 500 habitants qui a
un impact majeur sur toute notre
communauté puis ça permet de payer le
loyer ça permet de payer en fait les
assurances puis l'hypothèque pitié le
minimum si on avait été des
propriétaires comme les gens qui
achètent la rue Saint-Laurent en ce
moment qui augmente les loyers qui
mettent le monde dehors qui attendent
que ça tombe pour construire des condos
ben il y aurait pas de meneries il y
aurait pas ce développement là c'est
Adrien nous autres on a décidé de faire
le contraire de dire enfin le loyer le
moins cher possible pour donner une
chance à l'organisation
puis maintenant c'est bien parce que
pour nous autres on a fait ce mouvement
on a mis énormément de temps là-dedans
d'argent de rénaux de tout ça mais là on
arrive au bout de 10 ans puis
l'organisme est en mesure maintenant de
racheter le bâtiment ou nous on va
revendre le bâtiment mais à quelqu'un
qui veut faire perdre du riz la mission
de l'organisme de la meunerie
effectivement
puis Fred puis moi on on s'en cache pas
là nous autres on a fait ce qu'on avait
à faire avec cette organisation là avec
cette bâtiment là maintenant c'est le
temps de passer le flambeau parce qu'il
y a une autre on a d'autres projets puis
on estime que on ne sait on a fait ce
qu'on avait à faire autour de ça mais ça
c'est un modèle d'investissement
immobilier impact puis c'est ce qu'on a
refait après avec avec l'église de
Saint-Adrien ce qui est pas perdant dans
ce modèle là en fait c'est un modèle où
est-ce que tu
il y a des gens qui sont qui se
retrouvent à rue où il y a des gens
qu'il faut qu'ils se retrouvent un autre
loyer plus cher là c'est comme on achète
mais on est tout dans le même gang on
essaie de toutes celles et ensemble puis
on vend mais on dit on continue cette
mission là de toute montée ensemble en
gagne plutôt que pour passer du monde
pour toi faire plus d'argent exact c'est
c'est le fun parce que tu sais on l'a
tout de suite en gagne mais aussi tu
sais il faut comprendre que ça prend du
monde qui signe en bas de la page tu
sais l'hypothèque jour 1 là c'est Fred
puis moi qui l'a signé là
ok on signe comme l'église à
Saint-Adrien quand on l'a acheté mais
personne n'en voulait le la municipalité
en voulait plus il l'avait acheté il
faisait deux ans ça coûtait cher et on
voulait plus les autres promoteurs qui
étaient là avant ils en voulaient pas
non plus c'était comme un gros éléphant
blanc à personne voulait ça
puis là nous autres on est arrivé avec
projet 16-06 puis on a dit on va faire
l'acquisition de l'église puis on a
travaillé super fort après pour fonder
le BIM aller chercher les financements
aller chercher tout ce qu'il fallait
pour que ça fonctionne existe
mais ça prenait à la base quelqu'un qui
se dit puis pour le pourquoi de la
compagnie immobilière impact c'est que
si tu fais un OBNL puis tu as des
bénévoles là-dedans puis tu leur dis hey
demain l'OBNL va devenir propriétaire
d'un bâtiment où il faut mettre 600000
pièces pour pas que ça tombe puis que ça
va coûter 40 000 pièces d'assurance par
année qui veut signer
personne qui veut signer avec moi j'ai
eu la vision j'ai dit on va créer une
compagnie qui va signer pour ça parce
que je suis confiant que dans 10 ans on
va avoir été capable de prouver le
modèle plus souvent en état 5 ans avec
le BIM puis là-dessus on a trois ans de
pandémie puis on est encore là
est-ce que tu aurais cru
en contrebasse classique qui a 17 ans
que que tu mènerais autant de projets
entrepreneurial que ceux que ou tu étais
vraiment juste faire la musique puis
finalement la musique est ouvert
je pense j'ai toujours eu cette fibre là
contrebasse au Conservatoire c'est drôle
parce que j'étais
c'est comme un à 19 ans je pense quand
je suis revenu que je suis à la Toronto
à 18 ans je suis revenu à Montréal à 19
puis je jouais d'un bar tu jouais avec
des bluesmen puis tout ça avec avec
Ricard blues
alors ça te dit
non pas possible toutes ces gueuler il y
en a qui sont encore vivants là j'ai
j'ai adore toutes ça a été mon école
c'est de blues puis à l'époque c'est ça
j'étais dans le bain je te
contrebassiste puis tu m'avais pris
parce que j'avais un char je pouvais
faire des lift c'était ça aussi avec mes
autres bandes de tzigane si je pense
qu'à ce moment-là j'avais genre 17 ou 18
bandes en même temps là
c'est drôle parce que un de mes amis
François ils m'ont dit et puis lui il
dit engagé ils l'ont tu avais même pas
entendu jouer on savait juste que tu
avais une contrebasse tu avais un char
les gars déjà et après quand tu étais
avant première game tu avais joué entre
comme ok c'est bon on va le garder lui
mais bref j'étais au conservatoire puis
je m'étais pris un cellulaire à l'époque
pour pouvoir avoir une ligne parce que
j'étais aussi le beau cœur de mon bain
de blues puis je t'ai le beau cœur d'un
bluesman comme de 45 ans j'avais 19 ans
j'étais son manager je m'étais fait un
j'avais une page sur un site web d'un
ami c'était genre booking
stratège.tv je m'appelais Peter feeling
effectivement
je parle au téléphone demain mais je
bouquais des choux mais je bouquet des
choux de blues à 5000 pièces c'est comme
let's go puis c'est drôle parce que tout
se faisait par fax dans ce temps-là
aussi la secrétaire du Conservatoire
slid était
tellement
cool j'arrivais j'étais comme a faut que
j'en faudrait que je renvoie il faudrait
que je reçois un fax du de tel festival
qui était quand même le numéro
après l'avant-midi là j'avais deux trois
contrat signé si elle est contrat allez
renvoyer puis j'étais comme merci merci
tellement j'étais comme moi cette
journée là on a un concert d'orchestre
tu vas manquer le concert c'est quand
même
c'est j'aurais peut-être me trouver un
sub pour la gigue de blues puis je vais
être au concert d'orchestre je vais pas
chez ma session mais c'était ça c'était
déjà ça puis c'est tellement drôle
c'était tellement pas le c'est loin du
classique
surtout en classique tu sais que l'été
je veux dire les meilleurs vont devenir
faut jouer avec un orchestre
à peu près ça les gens les débouchés
normals d'étudiants la musique classique
puis là toi c'est comme dans l'ombre
créer mes opportunités puis je vais je
vais
doit apprendre à faire toutes ces job
connexes puis pour pouvoir amener
produire une vidéo clip de Kygo sur
d'autres plus on parle plus tu sors des
histoires qui dit voyons ça se peut pas
finalement il y en a tout le temps il y
a le temps de plus petit
au conservatoire en contrebasse
classique parce que c'est l'instrument
le plus tôt que j'ai pris dans mes mains
la baise la guide qui borde chantait
plus j'ai pris une contrebasse dans la
main j'ai fait comme oh votre Charles
fait que j'étais allé là-dedans si je
vois jamais vers le chemin facile je
pense si j'aime ça donner des défis puis
après ça c'est après un an à Montréal
j'ai eu un fausse quand le ship pour
aller au Glenn Gould School à Toronto
faut que j'étais là-bas j'ai découvert
des musiciens exceptionnels c'est
l'orchestre du conservatoire royal du
Canada c'était fou je pratiquais comme
un fou 8h par jour j'avais des cours
magistrats en anglais puis après ça je
suis revenu à Montréal
j'ai j'ai fini mon cégep parce qu'ils
ont pas crédibilité mon année à Toronto
puis après ça j'ai fait je me suis rangé
avec mon prof j'ai fait mon bac en deux
ans j'ai fait deux années en une
quand je suis revenu puis
j'ai vraiment clasher ça mais moi je
voulais étudier la musique classique
pour comprendre la musique parce qu'à 15
ans je savais pas lire la musique encore
comme du monde fait que quand je suis
arrivé conservatoire à 16 ans puis qui
m'ont retranché puis qui m'ont mis avec
des jeunes de 12 ans à se le faire
mais j'ai comme mon ego on a pris un
coup là avec les kids c'est comme ok
mais c'est qui de là sont au
Conservatoire depuis qu'il y a trois ans
sont vraiment meilleurs que moi je veux
moi aussi je vais être capable de
solfier de même puis moi aussi je vais
être capable de comprendre le
contrepoint l'harmonie l'analyse la
dictée tout ça fait que j'étais allé en
musique classique parce que c'était la
place pour apprendre la base de toute
puis une fois que tu as ça ben faire une
tonne pop ou tu sais où faire du jazz
c'est c'est la base la musique classique
effectivement je voulais ça mais
j'aurais pu aller en champ à Saint-Lô en
chant jazz puis j'aurais fait j'aurais
fait ça mais ouais
c'est ça
j'étais dans le conseil étudiant dans
radio étudiante j'ai envie communautaire
je tenais un sport j'étais dans
l'harmonie j'étais dans les combos de
jazz jouer au basket je vois si je
faisais du bois de la fin de semaine je
t'ai président du club de ski j'étais
j'ai toujours aimé ça être dans
l'organisation aussi ma mère est une JO
le joyeuse organisatrice puis je pense
que je suis un joyeux organisateur
j'aime ça quand on a une destination
d'un but puis on va tout ensemble puis
on s'arrange que personne se perde puis
quand il y aille c'est
à travers toute seule
moi quand j'ai beaucoup de trucs qui se
passent dans ma vie puis beaucoup que
mon cerveau est un peu éparpillé dans
plusieurs projets puis ces dernières
années ça arrive là mais comme mon
aspect créatif et disparaît complètement
je tombe un peu en mode genre
calculatrice le titre de répondre à des
mails de gérer les affaires puis j'ai de
la misère moi j'ai fait mon ma maîtrise
en littérature en création littéraire
fait comme j'avais cet aspect là que là
j'ai pu du tout je me suis dit de
m'accroître m'asseoir pour écrire puis
il y a rien qui se passe là je trouve
que c'est pas bon ce que je fais puis ça
marche pas toi malgré tout ça tu as
encore le la créativité facile autant de
de c'est sûr que quand tu fais des des
du scoring pour des films ou de la prod
c'est c'est créatif mais c'est pas ça
vient pas de de toi nécessairement
oui mais tu la création il y en a
partout pour moi le tir le le projet de
l'ancienne église de Saint-Adrien du BIM
comme ça pour moi c'est la question
c'est de la créativité à l'oeuvre dans
un contexte de prospective de
développement communautaire social
développement territorial mais
je comprends ce que tu dis parce que tu
vis tu sais puis là j'essaie de
m'arranger le plus possible pour quel
côté calculatrice
plan d'affaires tire relance tout ça
soit dans les mains quelqu'un d'autre
pas que je m'implique pas dans ces
choses là mais j'essaye de me dégager du
temps de plus en plus petit là avec la
pandémie c'est un crunch d'année plus
calculatrice puis moins de création un
moins de créativité parce que il y avait
tout plein d'enjeux si on a fait les
rénovations dans l'église construit les
studios tout ça mais là j'étais un point
dans ma vie où j'ai vraiment envie que
je comprends que mon x aussi
c'est vraiment la création fait que je
veux me remettre à faire plus de musique
déjà j'ai commencé l'année dernière
semaine j'avais des artistes à la maison
on fait des sessions de riding
j'ai plusieurs films en cours je veux
vraiment me remettre à écrire pour pour
moi là c'est pour mes projets
qui rafraîchissant je trouve de
t'entendre puis qui est inspirant c'est
que en fait des fois mettons c'est comme
si on oppose un peu création artistique
et puis être un artiste avec
entrepreneuriat puis avec Thierry
business puis tu sais comme si c'était
des choses qui étaient qui étaient comme
des Antilles antithèses c'est au final
je veux dire tu es entrepreneur tu fais
plein de projet mais la création
aussi décidément de
être gestionnaire du BIM pigeanté à être
plus le gars qui puis mettez tu fais
encore des musiques de films faire des
albums fêter le côté créatif côté
artistique en fait
j'ai l'impression que plutôt qu'à être
l'heure qui qui nourrit la Business la
Business nourrit l'or en fait parce que
justement ça t'amène aussi des nouveaux
projets le fait d'avoir créé le BIM
d'avoir créé d'artistes mais là ça amène
des projets aussi enfin que finalement
c'est c'est ça reste l'or on dirait
qu'il y a comme
tout le reste
puis que ce soit la création des autres
ou la mienne comme tu les artistes qui
sont signés sur burdhouse
tiens ils viennent passer du temps au
studio on co-créer ensemble on organise
des camps d'écriture on a fait foyer
foyers à l'automne dernier à l'église
avec 16 créateurs qui sont venus pendant
4 jours de créer des tonnes
si j'aime ça encourager la création
pitié justement faire en sorte que que 1
+ 1 + 1 = 8 qu'on soit qu'on crée de la
valeur ensemble puis c'est un beau
terrain de jeu justement pour faire ça
c'est quand par exemple il y a des
productions qui se font en esprit puis
qu'on est approché par des gens qui
disent moi je fais mon premier mon
premier long métrage on a fait un souci
au financement on n'a pas fou le budget
mais vous avez une bonne caméra on peut
dessus vous emprunter du matériel ou
faire un deal ou tout ça mais la mission
du BIM c'est dire oui on va s'arranger
pour que cette création là soit possible
puis on est allé chercher des
financements on fédéral puis au
provincial pour acheter ces équipements
de pointe-là si ça se loue 3000 pièces
par jour à Montréal puis que toi tu as
300 pièces par jour de budget ben on va
te louer à trois en pierre parce que
tu fais partie de l'écosystème puis une
autre mission c'est d'encourager
justement le fait qu'il y ait de la
création de contenu puis de la création
sur le territoire fait ça rentre dans
notre mission tu sais mais pour réaliser
ces missions territoriales là ça prend
le support c'est des barres de fonds des
gouvernements puis des sodecs de ce
monde du calque tout ça puis
en région on se rend compte que c'est
encore très Montréal au Centre toutes
ces aides financières-là fait que tu des
fois on se fait dire ah mais pourquoi
vous avez pas de maison de production à
Montréal on est une maison de production
régionale fake on veut encourager les
maisons de production régionale fake
c'est le
c'est un immense plaisir en fait de
pouvoir
grâce à de la Création qu'on a fait
depuis grâce à des projets qu'on a
montés de pouvoir participer à des
projets comme ça qui verraient pas le
jour si on n'était pas là c'est fixé là
qu'on voit vraiment qu'on a un impact
sur l'écosystème c'est ça à faire c'est
que c'est ça permet ça permet des trucs
impossible sans ça c'est
ça me parle beaucoup ce que depuis notre
conversation là je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant puis tantôt je réfléchissais
quand tu mentionnais tu sais que toi ta
blonde payée deux apparts deux
hypothèques de condo ou deux le studio
l'atelier puis là puis là je faisais
juste dans ma tête tantôt je me disais
je sais de calculer mettons le loyer ici
comme mon loyer ton loyer
j'ai loyers si puis l'autre musique
aussi
je calculais tout ça je me dis au final
ces ressources là mettons en région ça
vaut trois fois ça c'est dans le sens en
terme de ce que tu peux avoir
si tu si à la place de prendre trois
fois ça tu prends la même chose mais là
tout le reste tu peux le mettre dans ce
que tu veux on dirait que ça apparaît
tellement clair mais c'est tellement
c'est un saut dans le vide j'imagine
ouais en région ce qu'on essaie de créer
c'est c'est aussi c'est un un milieu de
vie pour les gens affectés moi je me dis
c'est tout ce que hypothétiquement tout
ce que vous mettez pas dans des loyers
ou dans des hypothèques à Montréal puis
que vous êtes en campagne puis que on à
go on est une cinquantaine de personnes
qui travaillent en créativité numérique
puis qui travaillent en création de
contenu puis qui travaille en or
pour l'ensemble tu dis eh ben à 50 là
notre extra loyer là on pourrait pas se
payer une grosse serre puis avoir des
légumes à l'année
si tu fais partie d'une organisation
puis que tu as des terres puis que tu
montes un projet intelligent comme faux
mais
[Musique]
mais ultra rentable aussi
aux instances gouvernementales puis au
bar de fonds
c'est pas porté par une personne c'est
porté par toute une collectivité puis
c'est de là l'idée un peu de
concept-là qui est la ruralité radieuse
que j'essaie de mettre que que je veux
mettre de l'avant dans les prochaines
années c'est vrai que tu écrives
parce que ça me fait penser à conscience
qu'on a l'homme fait penser à la
construction qu'on avait eu avec Jean
Martin Fortier le maréchal le jardinage
le concept est un peu celui-là de dire
ouais moi je vais aller là puis on va
tout le monde utiliser cette ferme-là
super rentable parce que son petit
Hector grâce à ces techniques sont comme
ultra rentables puis tout le monde en
bénéficie tu sais et puis ça ça ravive
la vie dans son coin de pays j'aime
beaucoup Jean Martin on fait des on a
des très bonnes discussions ensemble
dans des villages de 2000 habitants et
moins
731 au Québec des villages de 2000
habitants et moins si on faisait des
projets structurants comme ça dans une
centaine de villages
ça serait des impacts positifs qui se
calcule en termes de milliards de 5
milliards sur 5 ans en impact positif
sur l'économie du Québec dans les
régions mais là on parle même pas de
l'indice de bonheur on parle même pas du
fait que des gens qui mangent mieux qui
que leurs légumes ont fait moins de
chemin sur la route donc ça fait moins
de CO2 c'est les réductions de gaz à
effet de serre les impacts sur la santé
de l'humain les impacts sur les
communautés d'avoir des fermes comme ça
où on va créer du lien où il va avoir du
travail multigénérationnel où il va
avoir de la rencontre sur la santé
mentale sur l'éducation sur les
Allemands des personnages
toutes les facteurs de calcul qui
rentrent en ligne de compte
c'est fou l'impact que ça pourrait avoir
même sur la la capacité d'immigration du
Québec parce que oui régionaux qui
deviennent intéressants pour les
immigrants qui arrivent ici pour aller
utiliser leur talent leur capacité aller
dans dans ses plats la francisation
parce que elle était entouré de
personnes qui parlent français qui
t'accueillent qui t'accueillent dans ton
dans leur village c'est fou là la
capacité d'accueil du Québec serait
décuplée probablement avec l'application
de la rural radieuse à une échelle
provinciale
c'est que je suis vendu moi ça me fait
penser la conversation connue sur
l'intelligence artificielle le pas
longtemps
puis que justement on parlait de ville
d'identification
à l'idée de de dire la solution que la
solution ce soit la densification des
villes mais je me ça me faisait paniquer
d'entendre ça comme étant une solution
pour lutter contre les changements des
changements climatiques moi ça me
faisait paniquer ça c'est lui disait
on pourrait vivre dans un dans des
sociétés qui ont plus l'air de l'état de
nature mais optimiser par l'intelligence
artificielle qui fait que que justement
on a tout ce qu'on a besoin puis qu'on
utilise la technologie ça me fait penser
à ce qui se passe à cette Adrien
justement
de l'épicerie qui soit automatiquement
toutes les technologies pour finalement
revenir à une vie qui semble plus simple
qui semble plus plus naturel mais dans
mais sans faire aucun compromis sur les
qualités de vie c'est quand on regarde
le possiblement que l'intelligence
artificielle ça serait un moyen
d'optimiser nos processus puis
d'optimiser la vie ensemble puis tout
seul parce que
moi je suis parti d'un principe à mener
là j'ai plein d'amis agriculteurs à
campagne la même semaine je pense qu'il
y en a quatre qui m'ont dit ah moi
j'aurais besoin de besoin d'un employé
mais qu'une journée s'amène le vous êtes
4 à dire que vous avez besoin de
quelqu'un une journée semaine pourquoi
on fait pas venir une personne dans
région qui va pouvoir faire une journée
chez vous une journée chez vous une
journée chez vous puis c'est réglé ah le
les horaires
mettons-le hypothétiquement tu as un job
de toi à faire cette affaire là
de 1000 personnes dans ta région sur les
milles il y en a
cinq qui ont dit qui était bon aux
autres pour faire de la toiture
tu lances une requête dans une
application X qui n'existe pas qui est
géré par l'intelligence officielle en
sachant que ce qu'on sait de ce qui se
fait est assez simple c'est ça c'est
vraiment simple ça c'est simple
de faire c'est ultra simple tu lances
une requête moi j'ai besoin de faire mon
toit d'ici deux semaines ok mais là
l'intelligence artificielle peut prendre
en compte la météo
la disponibilité des matériaux dans des
environs la disponibilité des gens puis
va dire ah ben on a des dates tentatives
le mardi le jeudi puis lundi d'après
puis là les 100 personnes qui ont dit
qu'il était disponibles pour faire de la
toiture mais les high va savoir quand
est-ce qu'ils se sont mis disponibles ou
pas fixer ça s'il y en a 50 qui sont
disponibles c'est trois jours là ça la
renvoie une requête assez 50 là puis les
10 premiers qui disent oui je prends la
job mais là c'est booké dans leur
calendrier puis lui dans son calendrier
il va savoir que mardi il va avoir 10
personnes pour en faire son toit de
grange puis qui sont compétents parce
que l'application c'est peut-être une
méritocratie aussi c'est peut-être une
place moi je suis bon là finalement il
est pas très bon là-dedans et bien fait
mais pas très bon là
l'intelligence artificielle qui cause un
fou fait
les gens quand ils vont faire la job
seront même pas payés par le fermier ils
vont être payés sur l'application c'est
lui il va payer dans le Cloud puis eux
ils vont recevoir dans le Cloud puis à
ce moment-là on peut étudier que ça peut
être une blockchain un token régional
qui devient comme le billet de 20 pièces
coupées en Gaspésie ou ce que quand tu
dépenses localement ça vaut le double ou
ça devient-il une crypto ça devient sa
blockchain puis que là tu étais allé
aider fermier à faire son toit puis
soudainement tu as un mille pièces de
compte sur au sein vrac pour faire ton
pour faire des achats c'est ça qu'il
faut réimaginer le petit ça ça fait
partie de tes 80% d'idées dont tu parles
tu dis quelqu'un va pas nier
puis comme je comprends pas pourquoi au
Québec on a pas de transport en commun
on n'a pas un monorail avec le moteur
roux qui rende de Gasper à Toronto
ça je me l'explique mal c'est le moteur
rouge fait 50 ou 100 ans là je sais pas
là c'est complètement fou qu'on n'avait
pas mis ça à profit pour la société
québécoise
puis qu'on n'ait pas de transport en
commun qui fonctionne c'est des des
autobus des monorails des wher c'est
juste dans la petite MRC des petits
autobus électriques moi je le prends le
petit autobus électrique pour partir de
saint-ades aller à Val des sources enfin
mon épicerie puis revenir par le circuit
c'est comme prendrait deux autobus qui
font le tour il y aurait un départ à
toutes les heures de chaque bar
moi je suis contre les partis politiques
toutes les parties
je suis con l'idée de s'opposer
l'opposition il y a dessus de quoi de
plus aberrant que ça sont il y a du
monde intelligents des deux bars puis il
y a une proposition qui est faite d'un
côté puis l'autre côté va s'opposer
juste parce que ça job de s'opposer puis
après on va attendre quatre ans que
l'autre soit au pouvoir ils vont
proposer la même crise d'idée que les
autres qui ont proposé mais là ils vont
voter parce que c'était leur idée puis
ça leur mention fait que là
c'est c'est on arrive à rien avec ça
parce que je voudrais voir c'est genre
Françoise David puis pierre Carl
Péladeau qui s'entende sur une politique
culturelle économique et éducationnelle
genre qu'un problème qui se mette
ensemble pour trouver la solution oui
qui plaît aux deux et que la solution
découle d'une discussion et
d'arguments et de fait valable
il y a pas persiste je pense que que de
droite ou de gauche ça va se faire en
sorte que
la bourse va être mieux gérer peut-être
puis des fois on a l'impression que la
gauche gère mal les finances mais non
il y a des fiscalistes puis des
comptables partout là mais tu sais qu'on
retourne les problèmes sous tout leurs
angles puis qu'on les regarde pas juste
avec notre lunette de droite ou de
gauche puis qu'on abolisse les parties
parce que la partie zannerie je pense la
pire à faire c'est ça
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
Philippe Couillard quand il était
premier ministre il est venu à
Saint-Adrien deux fois puis cet homme-là
m'a beaucoup impressionné par son écoute
son intelligence c'est lui qui m'a
qui m'a mis en contact qui m'a fait
découvrir le travail de Le Corbusier
puis de la ruralité radieuse des
villages radieux
c'est
puis si j'avais écouté les gens de mon
entourage je leur ai jamais accueilli
le démon le démon en personne
mais je me suis dit si je ne vais pas à
la rencontre de cet homme je suis même
pas digne de de
critiquer ou même de porter mon nom
d'être
parce que
ce qui ce qu'il pire je pense dans les
relations humaines c'est la peur c'est
la peur qui drive les conflits c'est la
peur c'est la peur du manque la peur de
l'autre l'incompréhension puis quand on
va à la rencontre de quelqu'un que l'on
croit son contraire ou son opposé on se
rend compte qu'on a plein de points
communs plein de valeurs communes alors
pourquoi pas se concentrer sur ces
valeurs communes là puis travailler
ensemble pour faire advenir des futurs
souhaitables
c'est tout à fait depuis pas la plupart
du monde s'entende sur qu'est-ce qui
tire c'est quoi l'idéal en fait c'est ce
après ça on
s'entend pas souvent sur la manière de
l'atteindre type sur ce qui fait
vraiment des virgules mais ce qui
finalement aussi ça
ça ça se trouve objectivement aussi je
veux dire ça ça se calcule ou ça c'est
vrai il y a rien de Perm maintenant dans
la dernière élection où est-ce que c'est
le débat des chefs puis tout le monde se
garerache un chiffre en immigration ah
ouais tout le monde se garer un chiffre
tout le monde 8030
le calculer puis après ça peut-être ça
va varier selon sur quoi tu priorise
selon tes valeurs puis qu'est-ce que tu
priorises mettons mais calculons-le à
place de juste ce garocher des chiffres
arbitraire 45000
62%ages des nombres absolus des c'est ça
faut faire du sens de ces enjeux de
société là puis je pense que tant qu'il
va y avoir des partis politiques on sera
pas capable d'arriver là parce qu'il y
aura toujours opposition moi j'imagine
un genre de système là où chaque village
choisit son champion ou sa championne
puis ensuite au niveau des MRC
500 personnes dans l'église là puis là
c'est qui veut aller nous représenter
qui porte parole en choisis un ou une
dans ton village puis après maintenant
on a noté merci 7 villes villages fait
que les 7 que les villages ont choisi il
se rassemble ensemble ça vaut une salle
plutôt 7 copeaux qui arrivent là puis
disent bon le dmrc c'est qui qui est bon
pour passer au prochain à l'autre pour
aller nous représenter à l'autre palier
faites-le tu vas tout le temps voir la
main la meilleure personne la personne
choisie par le groupe pour vrai
publiquement qui vont être
des fois peut-être qu'il va avoir un
débat ou deux avant de choisir la perce
deux candidats vont dire et finalement à
lumière du débat qu'on vient d'avoir là
je pense que c'est toi qui devrait y
aller fake vas-y puis là finalement
l'autre va être choisi dans le cercle
pour aller encore plus haut fait que la
personne qui était deuxième ici va
devenir le
petit boss de son village
mais ça c'est le champion la championne
puis après ça sûrement plus haut puis ça
va toujours être quand tu vas arriver au
niveau de au niveau de l'esprit puis tu
as toutes les MRC mais dans toutes CMRC
là mais ils vont en choisir
un ou une qui va aller la prochaine
étape on va se ramasser avec 100
personnes à Chambre des communes qui ont
pas de partie puis qui sont les
meilleurs pour représenter le groupe qui
représente la région parce qu'ils vont
avoir été choisi démocratiquement par
débat public dans des petits groupes
pour accéder à prochaine étape
puis ça ça enlèverait les parties puis
il y a des moyens de faire ça le type il
y a des moyens aussi de faire des votes
électroniques
ma face reconnaît mon pouce reconnaissez
encore ouais pourquoi encore on n'arrête
pas de se plaindre des taux de
participation
que tu réponds à un courriel ou
peut-être on clique c'est que même puis
là tu mets ton pouce tu mets ta rétine
tu mets ta face ton dessous de pied je
sais pas n'importe quoi puis là cette
identifie puis tu peux même prendre un
témoin proche de toi qui dit ouais tu
sais j'étais moi
en danger il est en train de voter puis
c'est correct c'est sur des sur plein
d'enjeux on pourrait mettre ça en place
puis encore là intelligence artificielle
gestion des données
moi je pense le futur des régions aussi
passent par plus je rentre dans un autre
sujet là qu'on n'a pas le temps
d'aborder
le futur des régions passe aussi par la
scène gestion des données que la
souveraineté des données puis tu on
travaille sur un
prototype à Saint-Adrien de chaufferie
numérique ou en réutilise la chaleur de
serveur informatique pour chauffer
l'église depuis 5 ans maintenant puis là
de plus en plus je me rends compte que
l'accès aux données l'accent Internet
puis l'évolution de l'intelligence
artificielle va permettre beaucoup
d'innovation dans la vie des humains
puis dans le développement de nos
régions effectivement au lieu de faire
un cute comme son entrain de faire elle
les vit avec un point 2 milliards
d'investissement dans un immense centre
qui va mettre une pression sur le gris
d'Hydro-Québec dans ce coin là qui va
faire en sorte que ça va créer des mais
dans ce coin-là puis ils vont climatiser
tellement il y a des serveurs même les
verres vont climatiser mais de dire on
prend ça puis on fait une centaine de
centres de données à 12 millions partout
au Québec mais là tu viens de créer des
jobs en TI partout en région tu viens de
chauffer les bâtiments patrimoniaux
partout en région tu viens de connecter
tes régions puis tu viens
potentiellement de créer des notes de du
cerveau de l'intelligence artificielle
partout en région des centralisé
faites-le il y a un aspect
géopolitique à ceux qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que si nos serveurs
puis nos data sont décentralisés mais
c'est pas attaquable physiquement parce
que dès que un point tombe les 99 autres
prennent le relais
il y a une distribution des richesses
aussi à dans la province puis de la
connaissance parce que c'est un
spécialiste en TI en informatique dans
chaque village ça c'est du monde qui
arrive qui ont des enfants qui ont
peut-être une femme qui est médecin ou
qui infirmière ou qui est propre ou qui
est un chum qui est dans une autre
professeur métier ça permet de créer des
jobs de qualité en région d'installer
ces gens-là qui vont être pro puis
wheeling souvent à faire de l'innovation
puis petit aborder la technologie tantôt
la technologie au service du
développement de la collectivité puis de
des humains en région je pense c'est un
gros point qu'il faut qu'il faut
développer puis qu'il faut aborder
prochainement très intéressant même
merci beaucoup de temps et merci à vous
c'est super